[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur lcp
public sénat pour cette nouvelle saison
de parlement hebdo le meilleur de la
semaine à l'assemblée et au sénat avec
vous tam bonjourbonjour katia et cette
semaine on va notamment parler
immigration ou encore de la loi anti
gaspillage et on en parle avec alain
joyandet bonjour bonjour sénateurs les
républicains de la haute saône alain
joyandet
eh bien figurez-vous qu'on a retrouvé
d'abord vos papiers on va commencer avec
votre carte d'identité
alain joyandet vous êtes né en 1954 vous
êtes sénateur les républicains de la
haute saône
on l'a dit et vous êtes un homme fidèle
fidèle à votre territoire bien sûr un
vase ou d'un jour vesoul toujours maire
pendant 16 ans vous avez même présidé le
club de foot
mais pendant deux ans vous avez aussi
occupé la fonction de secrétaire d'état
à la francophonie nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque vous aviez démissionner pour
avoir affrété un avion privé dans vos
fonctions ministérielles touché
peut-être avant d'autre part les
attentes des français envers les hommes
politiques pour plus de sobriété
alain joyandet vous êtes aussi serial
entrepreneur 1 vous avez fondé de très
nombreuses entreprises alors pourquoi la
politique vous qui était si pris par vos
affaires
c'est l'engagement public président du
club de foot managers d'entreprises
reprise d'entreprises en difficulté
très récemment encore l' envie de faire
les choses avec les autres aussi je
pense que c'est c'est un état d'esprit
c'est l'entrepreneuriat c'est privé ça
peut être public voilà mais je crois que
c'est quelque chose que l'on a en soi
même on sait pas trop pourquoi au fond à
l'origine mais c'est bien comme ça eh
bien on va dérouler avec vous le film de
la semaine avec d'abord cette image d'
emmanuel macron qui a rencontré à huis
clos les parlementaires de la majorité
pour les inviter à regarder le sujet de
l'immigration en face le projet de loi
anti gaspillage déçoit les sénateurs
ils ont réécrit le volet du texte qui
prévoit le retour de la consigne
et puis un rapport du sénat dénoncent
les failles du système des pv avec
beaucoup d'amants non recouvrées manque
à gagner pour l'état et les
collectivités 1 milliard d'euros d'abord
emmanuel macron qui durcit le ton sur
l'immigration
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était ce lundi rencontre sans caméra
avec les députés et les sénateurs de la
majorité le président de la république a
abordé sans détour ce thème sensible
mari la bat à deux semaines du débat sur
l'immigration au parlement emmanuel
macron a prévenu sa majorité
nous n'avons pas le droit de ne pas
regarder ce sujet en face en prétendant
être humaniste
on est parfois trop laxistes un discours
que gauche et droite dénonce pour des
raisons opposées
il faut être clair on ne peut pas à la
fois ceux d'hier et de gauche et de
droite et avoir une politique sur les
l'immigration qui est un pur plus dure
que celle que l'on a connue il ya
quelques années sous brice hortefeux et
nicolas sarkozy c'est un vrai numéro de
bonimenteur seyssois du cynisme soit de
la naïveté du cynisme parce qu'il sait
pertinemment que rien ne changera
d'ailleurs c'est un débat sans vote donc
c'est des paroles pour le plaisir de les
de les prononcer au sein même de la
majorité certains parlementaires assume
la volonté du président de ne pas
laisser le thème de l'immigration à la
droite et à l'extrême droite en vue de
mais dans une tribune publiée cette
semaine quinze députés du groupe en
marche appelle à éviter une
hystérisation qui serait inversement
proportionnelle à la réalité migratoires
un an après l'adoption de la loi colons
le gouvernement réfléchit donc à de
nouvelles mesures sur l'immigration
alain joyandet emmanuel macron méthyle
les pieds dans le plat sur ce sujet de
l'immigration
moi je pense vraiment que sur ce sujet
il faut tout faire pour réussir à
trouver un consensus
voilà je pense qu'il faut qu'un enfin un
moment donné c'est pas forcément bien
parti non c'est pas bien parti mais tout
de même de la république en marche quand
nous abordions ce sujet je me souviens
de la création d'un ministère avec
nicolas sarkozy là ministère de
l'immigration et l'identité nationale
rappelez-vous le tollé que ça a pu faire
dans notre pays
si aujourd'hui emmanuel macron qui lui
même prend conscience d'un certain
nombre de choses mais peut-être que si
le déroulé de son plan de communication
si c'est ça c'est triste mais si
vraiment il prend conscience de
du problème que représente l'immigration
et qui part non est ce que pour vous
c'est un virage à droite est ce qu'il
est en train d'essayer de marché sur vos
plates-bandes
en faisant cela écoutez la question de
la stratégie politique sur un tel sujet
ne m'intéresse pas la question c'est
est-ce qu'un moment donné on va pouvoir
trouver une politique d'immigration qui
fasse un peu consensus dans notre pays
pour qu'on arrête de se jeter à la
figure des anathèmes
quand nous en parlions il ya quelques
années nous étions les homologues
quelque part du de l'extrême droite on
n'avait pas le droit d'en parler
emmanuel macron détient la parole
publique il est le président aujourd'hui
tout tourne autour du président si c'est
lui qui s'en emparent alors à ce moment
là c'est très bien mais il faut
impérativement qu'au bout du compte il
propose des choses sur lesquelles nous
soyons tous d'accord certes mais en
imposant à l'ordre du jour il ce sujet
de l'immigration président de la
république
est-ce qu'il va pas tout de même faire
monter les tensions au sein de sa
majorité
et du coup c'est finalement pas si mal
pour vous à ses divisions
franchement je ne regarde pas ça je
pense que le sujet est tellement
important pour l'avenir de notre pays sa
vie à des violences en ce moment en
france il ya un sentiment d'injustice
sur l'immigration en tant que telle
n'est pas les français
c'est pas le poème de l'immigration en
tant que tel c'est les conséquences de
l'immigration on parlera tout à l'heure
de l'est mais on parlera des hôpitaux on
parlera de sucre ressentent les français
en terme d' injustice parfois liées à
l'immigration
donc ce que j'attends de voir ce qu'est
ce que monsieur macron va nous proposer
sur l'immigration après dans sa majorité
il ya forcément des tensions c'est une
majorité de gauche et de droite ces
sujets n'avait-il pas déjà été traités
avec le projet de loi asile immigration
il ya quelques mois porté par gérard
collomb on se demande quand même ce que
ça vient à nouveau refaire sur le tapis
mais vous voyez bien que sur ce sujet
depuis des décennies tout le monde en
parle et personne ne fait vraiment les
choses
il suffit de vivre au milieu des
français y compris en haute saône pour
bien voir que c'est ça d'ailleurs un de
nos problèmes nous les politiques c'est
qu'on parle de certains sujets pendant
cinq jours six jours huit jours est
français on entende parler il n'y croit
absolument plus parce qu'ils se disent
toute façon rien ne va changer la
responsabilité du président actuel
c'est de recrédibiliser la parole
publique sur ce sujet vous saluer plutôt
cette position d' emmanuel macron de
vouloir remettre bien ce sujet à l'ordre
du
jour bien sûr mais je crois que si s'il
veut faire face à l'ensemble de ses
responsabilités de président de la
république il peut pas comme ça balayait
d'un revers de main la question de
l'immigration il en a conscience dans
lieux avec un sujet qui est revenu
directement dans le débat c'est celui de
l'aide médicale d'état qui permet à des
étrangers en situation régulière
d'accéder aux soins en france je propose
d'écouter ce qu'en dit le député de la
majorité olivier ferrand aujourd'hui à
l'heure à laquelle vous parle en étant
rapporteure générale des affaires
sociales je ne suis incapable de vous
donner la nationalité des bénéficiaires
de la m
par contre je travaille avec les ong qui
font un boulot incroyable sur le
territoire notamment médecins du monde
et qui ont des centres de soins pour les
précaires et qui nous disent même les
dispositifs que vous mettez en place
aujourd'hui ils sont par ailleurs pas
suffisant pour une certaine partie de la
population étrangère très précaire et
qui n'a pas encore accès aux dispositifs
de reconnaît donc peut-être que
peut-être revisité ça va permettre de
renforcer les soins là où c'est
absolument nécessaire et peut-être de
lever un certain nombre d'
incompréhension voire de préjugés là où
ils peuvent émerger
voilà on a un sujet concret là et me
l'aide médicale d'état est ce que vous
pensez que le gouvernement va la réforme
et la supprimer ou ne rien faire
en tout cas quand j'écoute le rapporteur
général de la somme initiale on est très
mal partie
personne ou presque en france ne sait ce
qu'elle a et me faut répéter quand même
la mc l'aide médicale d'état pour les
immigrés en situation irrégulière
je pense qu'il faut recadrer les choses
il s'agit pas des immigrés en situation
régulière des immigrés en situation
irrégulière d'accord 1 milliard plus
d'un milliard par an 9 935 millions pour
de prévisions pour 2010 9 heures ça va
peut-être être dépassée bonjour je suis
le rapporteur au sénat de la mg
notamment dans le cadre du plfss
donc c'est un dossier qu'il connaît un
peu quoi voilà et donc mais l'année
dernière en fin d'année on a rajouté de
l'argent sur la hem eu d'accord là quand
je vois qu'on met quelques centaines de
millions d'euros pour régler le problème
des urgences en france et qu'on met un
milliard plus d'un milliard sur la m e
pour les 6 10 et les immigrés en
situation irrégulière ça pose un
problème
c'est sur ces sujets là que je pense
qu'il faudrait pour la supprimer la
réforme et il faut faire quoi avec la
haine
je dis simplement qu'il faut la réformer
ça fait deux ans de suite au sénat que
je fais voté au sénat un amendement pour
passer de 1 milliard à 300 millions 2,2
1 milliards à 700 millions c'est le
montant 300 millions de moins voilà ce
que je demandais le sénat l'a voté
l'assemblée nationale a rétabli
qu'est ce que je dit jeudi sur la hem
pour que les français sentent qu'ils en
justice une justice qu'on laisse cet
aveu bien sûr pour les urgences pour les
enfants pour les accouchements pour les
situations d'urgence pour
l'épidémiologie pour tout ça mais pas
que ce soit quelque chose sans fin on ne
contrôle rien on rajoute des crédits au
fur et à mesure qu'ils avaient besoin
une précision en ce qui concerne
justement cette aide médicale d'urgence
quand nous étions au gouvernement nous
avons institué un ticket d'entrée 30
euros pro tour j'ai demandé au sénat de
leur est institué l'année dernière
évidemment l'assemblée nationale et
contre on nous sommes passés en 2011 en
2011 nous sommes passés du chiffre
auquel nous étions quand nous sommes
arrivés à 200 millions de moins quand
nous avons quitté les affaires
la msp était moins de 600 millions en
quelques années on a repassé un meilleur
pourquoi est ce que la gauche a voulu
supprimer cette responsabilisation y
compris des immigrés en situation
régulière ce qui s'est passé était
prévisible
évidemment les goûts sont repartis à la
hausse donc il faut là dessus un
consensus il peut y avoir un changement
de pied du gouvernement quand on voit
bien les derniers mots justement sur la
m e sur le fait que stanislas gaming
disent qu'il ya des abus
vous en réjouissez est ce que peut-être
ils vont aller bien venger contre projet
général quand j'écoute le rapporteur
général qu'est ce qu'il dit il dit qu un
certain nombre d immigrés n'ont pas
encore suffisamment accès donc j'ai pas
cru comprendre qu'ils voulaient je n'ai
rien ou si vous voulez je suis pas un
anti sociale jeu plutôt quelqu'un connu
pour être modérée dans ma famille
politique sur tous ces sujets mais
encore une fois il faut que les français
sentent qu'à une certaine mesure une
certaine justice voilà juste quand même
on pour notre téléspectateurs on
explique bien que la m est aussi utile
quand même là pour lutter contre des
épidémies pourvoi la maladie moi je
crois que c'est ce que je viens de dire
je n'ai pas dit qu'il fallait la
supprimer j'ai dit qu'il fallait la
réformer et plus et mieux la contrôler
ce que vous dites y'a pas cette
confiance il faut des contrôles il faut
pas que ce soit un droit de tirage
est-ce que juste encore une précision
pour qu'on voit de quoi on parle
un immigré en situation irrégulière
en france depuis plus de 3 mois il va la
préfecture faut être concret il va la
préfecture il apporte la preuve qu'il a
hébergée chez son cousin chez un ami et
qu'il est sur le territoire national
depuis plus de trois mois en situation
irrégulière on est obligé de lui
délivrer un certificat
quand même d'immigrés en situation
régulière depuis trois mois avec ça il
va à l'hôpital et les soins sont sans
fin est-ce qu'on peut laisser continuer
ça si on veut pas que les français
n'acceptent plus du tout l'immigration
eh bien on va avoir en tout cas tous ces
débats lors de l'examen du budget de la
sécurité sociale
alain joyandet on passe au deuxième
thème de cette émission la loi anti
gaspillage dont l'examen débute au sénat
et pas sous les meilleurs auspices
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le projet de loi porté par la secrétaire
d'état brune poirson déçoit les
sénateurs une mesure focalise
l'attention et la polémique la consigne
pour les bouteilles en plastique
explications de louis du mesnil je crois
qu'il faut à tout texte de loi son objet
transitionnel son symbole eh bien
peut-être que dans ce projet de loi ce
sera la consigne ce devait être la tête
d'affiche du projet de loi anti
gaspillage
la consigne en sera finalement le point
de crispation examiné par la commission
de l'aménagement du territoire le texte
a laissé les sénateurs sur leur faim la
secrétaire d'état avait pour objectif de
mettre en place la consigne d'ici la fin
du quinquennat
une consigne qui s'appliquera uniquement
aux bouteilles en plastique recyclable
un non sens écologique pour le président
de la commission est alors qu'il faut
mettre en place des solutions pour
cesser ce tout plastique
en créant cette consigne ont relégitime
la bouteille plastique et séduire par
hasard si un certain nombre
d'industriels au premier rang desquels
coca cola sont absolument à fond pour
cette mesure bien mais peut mieux faire
voilà ce qui ressort de cet examen
le projet a été retoqué le gouvernement
voulait élargir le concept de
pollueur-payeur aux producteurs de jouer
de tabac et de matériaux de bricolage
les sénateurs eux vont plus loin et vise
les fabricants de textiles sanitaires
comme les serviettes hygiéniques et les
couches qui représente 33 kg de déchets
non recyclables par an et par habitant
le volet environnemental laisse à désiré
en fait on est en deçà de ce que nous
sommes en mesure d'attendre d'un texte
qui a été annoncé comme quand même un
grand texte de l'acte 2 du quinquennat
parmi les autres retouches faire payer
les producteurs de déchets pour financer
la lutte contre les décharges sauvages
calqué sur les objectifs européens le
projet de loi a mis le cap sur 100 % de
plastique recyclé en 2025 contre 50%
aujourd'hui
alain joyandet d'abord votre réaction à
cette accusation d'hervé morère le
président de la commission du
développement durable au sénat pour lui
et bien le tactile est sous l'influencé
soul influence des lobbys il dit
notamment recevoir des kilomètres de
mails de coca cola oui c'est sur ces
sujets sur ces sujets du gaspillage du
recyclage on est souvent dans des
séquences de communication alors que
beaucoup de choses ont été faites y
compris par les collectivités
territoriales
et pour en revenir à cette fameuse
consignes de la bouteille je pense que
c'est une fausse bonne idée
pourquoi c'est une fausse bonne idée
parce que déjà on n'a pas expliquer aux
français ce que c'était il s'agit pas de
leur faire payer c'est d'abord ils vont
payer quand ils ont acheté leurs
bouteilles d'eau ils vont payer 20
centimes d'euro en plus s'ils veulent
récupérer leurs impôts en plissés puis
s'ils veulent récupérer leurs bouteilles
en plastique avec leurs 20 centimes pour
récupérer leurs 20 centimes ils devront
aller porter leurs bouteilles d'eau
quelque part chez un récupérateur ou
autre chose c'est ce que j'ai compris de
du texte cette bouteille ne sera pas
réutilisés mais elle sera également
recyclés
ça existe dans nos collectivités
territoriales dans mon département
si cette loi s'applique ça veut dire que
tout ce qui est fait dans ce qu'on
appelle chez nous le site évoque le
syndicat qui s'occupe de ça qui est
formidable qui a d'ailleurs été visité
par le ministre de l'ecologie qui était
félicité hé bien on va lui enlever une
très grande partie de son travail
puisque du coup les bouteilles ne vont
plus arriver là les investissements qui
sont prévues vont être arrêtés et en
plus ce sera inefficace donc quand il ya
un problème en france ont choisi un
totem comme ça et pendant 8 jours d'itt
a fragilisé les collectivités locales et
leurs systèmes actuels savoir un cetain
c'est un impôt supplémentaire 2 ça
fragilise les collectivités
territoriales et j'émets quelques
réserves
j'émets quelques réserves sur
l'efficacité parce qu'il va bien falloir
construire un réseau supplémentaire donc
comment tout ça va se va s'organiser
ça tombe à toute vitesse sans réflexion
associant associant les collectivités
territoriales à cette réflexion pour
savoir comment on peut faire encore plus
mais vous savez le taux de recyclage des
plastiques est énorme dans notre pays ça
se passe plutôt bien
brune par son a tout de même dit lors de
son audition que son projet de consignes
restée ouverte
voulait bien le refaire avec les
collectivités vous remarqué qu'il ya
quand même une porte ouverte du côté du
gouvernement
je l'entends très bien alors vous me
demandez de réagir sur ce qu'est le
projet de loi donc je réagis sur ce
qu'est le projet de loi si ce projet de
loi est amendable
si on peut en parler ensemble et qu'on
peut le modifier une fois de plus et si
on peut trouver un consensus
est-ce que la consigne pour vous
conforte la production et la
consommation de plastique
c'était ma question pardon je vais
répondre à la question déjà jusqu'à
preuve du plastique en lui même quel est
le problème du plastique le problème du
plastique c'est surtout prennent de la
récupération et du recyclage qu'on ne
retrouve pas le plastique par tous les
produits de substitution aux plastiques
aujourd'hui si on dit on si on dit d'un
seul coup j'ai une industrie dans ma
région mille emplois qui fabrique de
tous les emballages plastiques si on
leur dit au 1er janvier
il ya plus de plastique ces mille
personnes sur le carreau ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas faire mais il faut
regarder quels sont les produits de
substitution et est-ce qu'on peut
recycler les produits de substitution
voilà la question donc le plastique en
soit c'est pas son existence c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait comment le
recycler à quoi ça sert n'est pas à
jeter tout de même dans ce projet de loi
effectivement la tension n'a été
beaucoup focalisé sur la question des
consignes mais il ya aussi lutter contre
l'obsolescence programmée et l'agent du
principe du pollueur payeur a quand même
des bonnes choses sourit texte du
gouvernement
bien sûr je pense que comme dans tout
projet de loi il ya des choses qui sont
intéressantes
il faut en discuter il faut aller voter
vous savez au sénat parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de des gens qui sont
constructifs qui sont ceux qui
s'opposent pas à tous moi je sais pas
vous poser
j'ai du mal à me poser parce que je suis
un homme de projet vous l'avez dit tout
à leurs chefs d'entreprise
moi j'aime faire des choses j'aime avoir
des projets j'aime réussir avec tous
ceux qui sont avec moi
critiquer c'est il faut le faire
l'opposition un devoir républicain
mais bon au sénat c'est pas notre état
d'esprit qu'est ce qu'on fait avec une
loi on la jette pas on discute les
sénateurs travaillent vous venez de le
dire
on garde ce qui est bien ce qui est
moins bien on le on l'enlève puis après
l'assemblée le sénat discute en sang il
y avoir un accord ce texte entre députés
ce data et a beaucoup de deux
commissions de concilier tous les
projets de loi sur tous les projets de
loi quand il n'ya pas de jusqu'au
boutiste ni d'un côté ni de l'autre
on arrive toujours à s'entendre c'est ce
qu'on appelle la commission mixte
paritaire
alors troisième thème de cette émission
à la georgia des les amendes les
automobilistes se plaignent d'être un
peu des vaches à lait
[Musique]
un rapport sénatorial montre que
l'argent du par les contrevenants
n'arrivent pas toujours à bon port
manque à gagner pour l'état et les
collectivités près de 1 milliard d'euros
samia déchire nous explique en détail
les failles du système
excès de vitesse stationnement gênant
en tout 34 millions d'avis de paiement
ont été émis en france l'an dernier
lorsqu'ils sont majorées la plupart ne
sont jamais payés d'après un rapport de
la commission des finances du sénat
le taux de recouvrement des amendes
n'était que de 28,6 pour cent en 2018
est de 26 4% pour les forfaits poste
stationnement le manque à gagner pour
l'état est énorme
700 millions à un milliard d'euros par
an la faute d'après des sénateurs au
trop grand nombre d'acteurs impliqués
dans le recouvrement celui des fps par
exemple les forfaits poste stationnement
si vous avez afp s il faut dans la ville
contesté si c'est refuser il faut aller
au contentieux de limoges et pour payer
il faut aller d'arrêt trésorerie de
votre ville autre recommandation du
sénat accélérer le déploiement d'un
nouveau système informatique le logiciel
de recouvrement a aujourd'hui plus de 25
ans il faut que l'administration qui
doit recouvrer fonctionne avec ce vieux
logiciels qui ne permet pas certaines
choses par exemple si vous avez deux
employeurs de pouvoir indiquer deux
employeurs si vous avez une adresse
l'ombre de l'intégrer dans le dispositif
artias pas suffisamment de gaz et donc
on a un dispositif qui est totalement
obsolète
dans son rapport la commission des
finances du sénat dénonce aussi quelques
absurdités les personnes à mobilité
réduite par exemple ne sont pas censés
payer leur stationnement
si elles reçoivent par erreur une
contravention elles doivent d'abord
payer pour pouvoir contester les
sénateurs proposent de supprimer cette
règle du paiement préalable à la
contestation
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
est ce que vous êtes surpris par le
constat que fait ce rapport dont le sais
ça fait des faits ses potes c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui donc à chaque fois qu'on
veut s'attaquer à ce problème finalement
on n'y arrive pas c'est beaucoup trop
complexe ce que je veux dire en
préambule c'est qu'en tant qu'élu de la
république
belle au civisme j'en appelle à ce que
quand on a une contravention on la paye
si on considère qu'elle est méritée
si on considère que les peaux méritait
un certain nombre de systèmes qui font
que on peut la contester mais voyez ça
c'est aussi l'illustration
c'est mon analyse mais je monte
illustration de la justice qui est
ressenti par un certain nombre de
français
on parlait tout à l'heure d'immigration
dans me2 qu'est ce qu'ils voient autour
d'eux les français ceux qui travaillent
ceux qui se déplacent eux qui payent ils
ont le sentiment il voit qu'autour d'eux
tout est permis
rien n'est puni et puis eux quand ils
vont chercher une baguette de pain il
reste une minute de plus quand ils
prennent ce qu'ils appellent une prune
et la prune y sont obligés de la payer
parce que eux comme on les connaît comme
ils ont une adresse comme il travaille
comme ils ont un peu d'argent
ceux là on les fait payer et on al
impression qu autour de soi et bien les
lois de la république ne sont pas
respectées donc il faut retrouver un
ordre juste dans notre pays et peut-être
que les gens du coup seront plus
attachés ou civis le brésil moi je paye
mais les autres donc c'est un état
d'esprit
terrible pour l'avenir de notre pays un
an et bien sûr ce chiffre quand même qui
est sorti par ce rapport un milliard
d'euros de manque à gagner
c'est quasiment le budget de leyme pour
eux d'y revenir à notre thème de tout à
l'heure c'est tout de même énorme pour
et bien les caisses des collectivités et
l'état
bien sûr mais c'est ça pour les pvc
d'autres chiffres pour la fraude fiscale
c'est d'autres chiffres encore pour les
coûts sociaux qui ne sont pas savez la
triche
la triche mais aussi des sénateurs qui
s'occupe de la triche sur les
prestations sociales
voyez c'est tout ça qui fait qu' on est
dans un pays où les gens se dit ils se
disent nous voir ils voient que les gens
ne respectent pas les lois de la
république pour plein de sujets et eux
quand ils ont une prune il faut qu'il
annonce je ne les excuse pas je vais
surtout pas les excuses et qu'on ne se
méprenne pas mais il faut retrouver un
respect un respect sur tous les sujets
c'est très difficile et ça sera très
long à reconstruire pour vous pour vous
ces recours vous dites c'est de la
triche
quand on voit qu'un recours sur deux
aboutit du coup vous vous dites que
c'est une incitation à faire encore plus
de recours non je me dis que si un
recours sur deux aboutit ça veut dire
que aussi là peut-être qu'ils sont si ça
veut dire qu'il ya peut-être des pv
qu'ils sont justes il ya des pv qui sont
injustes et donc il faut pouvoir quand
il faut pouvoir contester ce qui sont
injustes et obtenir une satisfaction
est-ce que c'est aussi la faute à
l'automatisation des contrôles et aussi
tout ce débat sur ces mères qui ont
recours à des sociétés privées pour
mettre les amants
dans leur ville je pense que tous les
systèmes qui ont été testées aucun
d'entre eux n'a montré son efficacité
non pas en termes de verbalisation
puisque la verbalisation c'est assez
facile à faire
ce qui compte c'est de faire payer les
pv mais pour l'instant je vois pas de
solution nulle part et de faire payer
les bonnes personnes aussi oui oui de
faire payer aussi les bonnes personnes
c'est ce qu'essaie de faire d'ailleurs
le rapport sénatorial
je veux saluer le travail qui a été fait
par nos collègues parlementaires qu'ils
essaient de chercher une solution pour
améliorer la situation il faut bien dire
que c'est très compliqué vous parler de
triche il ya aussi des d injustice
flagrante puisque les véhicules flasheur
verbalise parfois des personnes
handicapées qui doivent payer leur
amende
avant de pouvoir la contester est ce que
pour vous c'est c'est une institution
c'est une illustration supplémentaire du
manque de justice est d'organisation
pour que la sanction soit juste et
qu'elle s'adresse aux bonnes personnes
mais où est la solution
je vais pas dire que je l'aimé moi ce
jeu je serais menteur alors on quitte ce
problème franco français pour un petit
peu d'international puisqu'on va
terminer avec une image c'est emmanuel
macron qui fait la une du times
américain on le voit alain joyandet il
se remonte les manches vous quel est
votre interprétation de cette image à ce
qu' il est à la tâche
ou est-ce qu'il a encore bien du boulot
à faire bien du boulot pour l'exécutif
et pour réformer la france
bon la photo a été choisi avec son
accord personne n'en doute
les initiants n'ont qu'a donc s'ils se
retrousse les manches ça veut dire qu'il
veut faire passer le message qu'en
france il faut il faut se retrousser les
manches
ce que je veux dire emmanuel macron est
devenu une star il est devenu une star
mondiale de la politique nicolas sarkozy
en son temps a été une star mondiale de
la politique et sur ce genre de
personnage repose une responsabilité
particulière
c'est pour ça qu'on ne peut pas
souhaiter l'échec des manuels macron
parce que si emmanuel macron venait à
échouer
compte tenu de son mieux son image
mondiale aujourd'hui ce serait terrible
pour la france voilà donc il faut qu'il
écoute il faut qu'ils regardent à sa
droite et à sa gauche ce qui se passe
pour essayer de réussir pour mon pays
pour notre pays je suis pas là dans la
politique politicienne et réforme au pas
de course pour vous pardon est-ce qu'il
réforme au pas de course dans le bon
sens je pense qu'il enclenche les sujets
mon pas de course sur le plan de la
communication les choses sont
enclenchées au pas de course ce qu'il
faut vraiment faire à un moment donné et
la selle responsabilité d' emmanuel
macron j'allais dire c'est une ultime
responsabilités avant l'arrivée des
populistes il faut qu'on arrive à mettre
en adéquation les discours les sujets de
communication et le fait que les
français se disent enfin ça change le
jour où les français diront enfin ça
change
ce qu'on nous dit on le voit on le fait
à ce moment là je pense que pour la
république
ce sera un atout formidable pour
l'avenir toute petite question est-ce
que manuela gross le nouveau nicolas
sarkozy parce que vous avez fait
l'analogie est il ya un instant j'ai pas
fai d'analogie j'ai dis juste que l'un
et l'autre ont été des stars mondiales
de la politique
nicolas sarkozy avait dit lui même
d'ailleurs que quelque part il y voit là
il y avait quelques analogies faillite
je dois dire très objectivement que je
retrouve quand même certains traits
communs merci alain joyandet ce sera
donc le mot de la fin
et oui merci beaucoup katia c'est donc
la fin de cette émission se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à la même heure avec
un député
[Musique]